this video is kindly sponsored by
masterworks find out more later on
hey 42 here it's believed there are at
least a hundred billion planets in the
milky way the galaxy we call home that's
one hell of a lot of planets in just one
galaxy now if you take into account that
some studies have estimated there could
be up to two trillion galaxies in the
observable universe
then it surely isn't beyond the realms
of possibility that one of those planets
might be home to an alien civilization
not too dissimilar to our own
unfortunately getting up there and
having a good look around is far beyond
the realm of the technology that we
currently have at our disposal
at present piloted space exploration is
seemingly limited to a few billionaires
using it as their own personal
playground and more importantly to see
who has the largest and sturdiest rocket
but what if there is an alien
civilization out there with technology
far exceeding our own
and
they've already been here over 70 years
ago
well if the residents of roswell new
mexico are to be believed
that's exactly what happened in 1947
when an extraterrestrial flying saucer
along with its alien passengers is said
to have been recovered by the us
government after crash landing into the
desert
the event would come to be known as the
roswell incident and it's considered by
many to be the largest government
cover-up of all time
if you've long been hoping to wake up
one day and find an almost priceless
banksy artwork has been painted on the
side of your house then you probably
already know there's enormous value in
art the total wealth that is held in art
is estimated to be worth 1.7 trillion
dollars and now thanks to masterworks
dot io you can invest in the very same
exclusive art collections that the
world's billionaires already invest in
when it comes to selling art masterworks
knows what they're doing they actually
return 32 to their investors in 2020 by
selling a work by banksy and it's super
easy to get involved in just a few
clicks you can visit their website
create an account browse their artwork
then diversify your portfolio with one
of the most stable assets around in fact
contemporary art prices outpaced the s p
500 total return by 174 percent from
1995 to 2020 according to publicly
available data masterworks also operates
a secondary market on their website so
if you don't want to wait until they
find a buyer for a piece you can
actually sell yours to another member if
you want to take advantage and invest in
fine arts there is currently a waiting
list however you can actually skip that
wait list and immediately start
investing now by clicking the link in
the description below and it also really
helps to support my channel
to find out what really happened at
roswell all those years ago we're going
to have to wade through deception that
leads to deception covered up with a red
herring by a bunch of folk who seem
rather deceptive
yeah
this one's a strange one so strap
yourselves in
for some classic mystery
oh and did i mention deception
on the 24th of june 1947 amateur pilot
kenneth arnold was flying solo over the
scenic landscapes of mineral in
washington
arnold had been hoping to find the
wreckage of a plane that he thought had
crashed landed in the area and claimed a
reward for solving the mystery of its
disappearance
although he never found said plain wreck
he witnessed something during that
flight that sparked a nationwide
obsession with unidentified flying
objects
arnold claims to have seen a bright
bluish light flash across the sky
followed closely by nine flying objects
traveling in unison at breakneck speeds
and maneuvering in ways that were fought
impossible even by the most advanced
military aircraft of the time
later when arnold was interviewed by the
press he described the objects as moving
like sources being skimmed across a lake
and it seems that this fairly innocuous
description was misinterpreted and some
assumed arnold was actually describing
the shape of the objects themselves
the following day news of his sighting
was plastered across the front pages
with a novel phrase that would embed
itself in popular culture from that day
on
flying saucer arnold's ufo sighting was
one of the first to be recorded in
post-war america and his position as a
well-respected businessman meant few
people questions the authenticity of his
story the news spread like wildfire and
would spark hundreds of copycat
sightings
before you knew it barely a day passed
by without somebody claiming to have
seen something flying around in the sky
that looked as though it had derived
from another planet whether there was
indeed a raft of ufo visitors around
that time or people were just getting a
bit jittery about post-war nuclear
tensions between the u.s and the soviets
so extra attention was being paid to
strange objects in the skies is unknown
but what we do know is that this mass
paranoia was about to come to a head
outside a small city in the new mexico
desert
called roswell
a few weeks after arnold's flying
saucers had entered the american
consciousness a rancher by the name of
mack brazil was traveling roughly 80
miles northwest of roswell
when he spotted something a little
different to the endless sand and
tumbleweeds that he was so used to
there on the ground in front of him was
what brazil described as
a large area of bright wreckage made up
of rubber strips tin foil and rather
tough paper and sticks which i'll be
honest sounds more like the materials a
dodgy landlord would use to fix his
tenant's boiler rather than
intergalactic transportation apparatus
he informed the sheriff of his discovery
the sheriff reported it to a nearby air
force base from there the news worked
its way up the chain of military command
until it arrived at the desk of
intelligence officer major jesse marcel
he was given the assignment of visiting
the crash site and recovering any
materials he found
marcel had played a significant role in
the atomic bomb test that the american
military had carried out in bikini at
all presumably this made him an
authority figure on futuristic
technology falling out of the sky
however marcel seemed as perplexed by
the wreckage as brazil had been
the wreckage was recovered and further
examined and a short time later the air
force issued a press release stating
that they were now in possession of a
mysterious flying disc that had
crash-landed in new mexico
unsurprisingly this only served to stoke
the ufo fire that was raging across the
country the following day the roswell
daily record published news of the
wreckage along with the sensational
headline
raaf captures flying saucer on ranch in
roswell region
okay so headlines weren't quite as
snappy back then and they didn't include
the mandatory pun
but it was enough to send the locals
into a frenzy
now i should point out that flying
saucer didn't actually mean the air
force were admitting the wreckage was of
extraterrestrial origin
simply that they had recovered the
wreckage of an unknown flying object
nevertheless releasing the statements
that strongly implied they were in
possession of the ufo
probably wasn't the smartest move
as you can imagine there were quite a
few people further up the military
command that were less than happy with
how brazil's discovery was being handled
and pretty soon shadowy moves were being
made to contain the hype that was
building around the incident
a military superior named general roger
ramy requested that the wreckage be
brought to him so he could see for
himself whether or not aliens were
indeed planning on invading earth by
strategically smashing their very
expensive spaceships into some sand and
of course when he finally laid eyes on
this enigmatic wreckage it was rather
unassuming
in fact it looked exactly how brazil had
first identified it
bits of rubber tape foil and wood
the air force released another statement
this time claiming the wreckage belonged
to a weather balloon this was closely
followed by the roswell daily record
issuing an apology for may be jumping
the gun a little and finally the man who
discovered the wreckage mack brazil told
everyone that he felt a little bit silly
for the trouble he'd caused and
expressed his regret at reporting the
wreckage in the first place
and so with all those loose ends
suspiciously but conveniently tied up
america seemed to completely forget
about the roswell incident and instead
turned its attention to fast food
munching clowns elvis presley's gyrating
hips
nuclear-powered cars and scantily clad
women in buddy girl outfits
yeah the 50s were a strange decade
roswell it appeared was an open and shut
case
indeed roswell was forgotten about for
30 long years
until in the 70s a nuclear physicist and
professional ufologist apparently that's
a thing by the name of stanton friedman
decided to revisit the roswell incident
and
he quickly realized some underhanded
cards had been played by some very
powerful
and mysterious people back in 1947.
as he would soon find out there was much
more to the roswell incident than the
american public had been told
friedman began his investigations by
interviewing jesse marshall
the air force major who'd been one of
the first people to visit the crash site
now you might have expected marcel to
simply corroborate the official story
however what marcel told friedman was
simply out of this world
marcel claims that back in 1947 he'd
been ordered to stay quiet about what
had really crash-landed in roswell he
told friedman that amongst the wreckage
was a strange foil-like material
marcel had handled this material himself
and he recounted how
it was completely weightless and
extremely thin
but the strangest thing was that he was
unable to bend it no matter how hard he
tried this sliver of material was also
completely impervious to dents or
scratches
and marcel was a man who knew his metals
in his role as military intelligence
officer he knew every material that was
used to construct aircraft and this
mysterious substance
was totally unlike any of them
he could only conclude that this
material and hence whatever had
crash-landed in the desert
was not from this planet
naturally at this point friedman was
salivating for more information and he
continued to interview over a hundred
roswell residents and first-hand
witnesses of the incident
not only did many of them verify
marcel's claims but some said they had
even seen alien bodies being recovered
from the crash site after friedman
published his findings interest in the
roswell incident was reignited as the
years passed conspiracy theories
surrounding the incident garnered global
attention and the town itself turned
into a sort of
extraterrestrial disneyland with ufo
stores and themed cafes and bars
littering the desert landscape
my personal favorite is the roswell
branch of mcdonald's oh ronald you witty
bastard
over the decade roswell fever continued
to grow
until
in 1994 it was blown wide open
the official government files of the
incident were declassified and made
available to the public
unbelievably the documents revealed that
roswell was in fact a cover-up
but don't get too excited because the
official record states that the weather
balloon alibi was made up by the
military to deflect attention away from
a top secret research program underway
during the roswell crash back in the
late 1940s
this program was called project mogul
and its goal was to create a high
altitude covert listening device that
could detect nuclear missile launches
from thousands of miles away in
seconds you see post-war america was a
country gripped by paranoia global
powers were in the process of being
redivided and redistributed a tense
situation that was made even more
precarious by the small matter of
nuclear bombs now being a thing
america of course had dropped two of
them on hiroshima and nagasaki so it was
no secret the u.s had the ability to
produce nuclear weapons
but as yet it was completely unknown
whether or not russia had managed to
successfully harness this devastating
power
a concept which to put it mildly made
america feel slightly queasy
and this is where project mogul came in
project mogul aspired to send
microphones up into the stratosphere
using high altitude balloons similar to
weather balloons
and then used those microphones to
detect sound waves caused by soviet
atomic bomb tests
it was based on the fact that underwater
microphones were already being used at
the time to detect explosions from great
distances across the oceans the balloons
used in project mogul were enormous far
larger than normal weather balloons and
made from a durable polyethylene plastic
that could have easily been
misidentified as something of a worldly
when discovered by a humble rancher
making his way across the desert
the balloons were also fitted out with
highly sophisticated and state of the
1940s art microphones and radio
transmitters which to the untrained eye
could have given the appearance of
advanced intergalactic debris
now
that all sounds fairly plausible project
mogul and its high-tech balloons were a
real thing at the time and they just so
happened to have been tested in the
desert right outside roswell but then it
does seem rather ironic and blissfully
convenient
that the whole weather balloon cover-up
story turned out to be a cover-up for
well just another weather balloon
only a slightly fancier one it's as if
in 1994 the government suddenly needed a
cover-up for their cover-up and thought
we'd all be easily duped by saying hey
don't look at those bog standard weather
balloons over there
we made those up
it was actually one of these fancy
weather balloons that crashed in the
desert and totally not a ufo
if you believe that the classified
documents then they explain the wreckage
and they sort of flimsily explain the
unusual materials found at the site
but
what about the alien bodies that
witnesses claim to have seen in the
desert
well
in 1997 the us government released a
report explaining that crash test
dummies had been used to test the
effects of parachutes on human beings by
quite literally dropping the dummies
from aeroplanes over several designated
drop zones
one of which happened to be roswell new
mexico
the sight of these dummies being pulled
out of the sun by government officials
could easily have given the appearance
of an alien body being retrieved from a
crash site
especially giving the ufo hysteria that
was whirling around at the time however
there is one small problem with this
explanation
those tests weren't carried out until
the 1950s
years after the roswell incident had
taken place
when the government were asked about
this discrepancy they simply explained
it away as people misremembering the
details of their own sightings
which all sound a little too men in
black if you ask me
today the roswell incident is probably
the most famous close counter conspiracy
in human history
and unfortunately we still don't have an
answer as to what crashed into the
deserts that day
in 1947 every way you turn there's a
different conspiracy to get lost in or
you could simply believe the official
pimped out weather balloon and chucking
people out of planes version of events
but before you do
let me just leave you with this
many decades later when documents
concerning the roswell incident were
requested it was discovered that all the
key military documents in the months
immediately surrounding the crash
were at some point
mysteriously destroyed and the creepiest
part
nobody knows why they were destroyed
or by whom
so today all we have are the time worn
words of eyewitness accounts
and very little else
but whoever you believe
one thing is clear
somebody
or something out there
doesn't want us to know what really
happened
a little over 70 years ago
in roswell
new mexico
[Music]
thanks for watching